hey guys I want to talk about
cholesterol deficiency now I know you've
been taught that you need to lower your
cholesterol so far down because it's so
dangerous it's going to clog your
arteries but here's the facts there are
way more problems with low cholesterol
than there is with high cholesterol
let's just let's just take let's say you
had high cholesterol high total
cholesterol do you realize that the risk
for heart attack would only be 0.1%
increase that's 1/10 of 1% so if I were
to tell you because of your high
cholesterol you have 1/10 of 1% chance
of getting a heart attack would you take
the medication probably not right the
amount of problems that occur with low
cholesterol depression cancer strokes a
or tick dissection where that's where
the aorta just splits and that would
cause a stroke obviously internal
bleeding prone to suicide Wow
pry from the depression right why
because cholesterol is necessary to make
hormones short-term memory loss in the
elderly susceptible to infection
including MRSA it's probably why so many
people at the hospital getting MRSA
because they put them on statins
increased risk for a increased chance of
getting allergy or asthma you can
actually improve allergies and asthma by
giving the person vitamin D but to get
to make vitamin D you need cholesterol
so here's the thing
in 1994 low cholesterol would be
considered like 160 or less nowadays
people are trying to get it down to like
110 and they think that's healthy I put
some links down below so you can learn
about the facts about cholesterol but
what you need to know is there's way
more problems with low cholesterol than
there is with high cholesterol so let's
talk about the foods that are highest in
cholesterol okay if you wanted to raise
your cholesterol if it was too low now I
don't consume brain but brain would be
the highest
cholesteral you can possibly consume
which is interesting because your brain
are 20% cholesterol we need the
cholesterol to feed our brains so you
can also get an organ meats liver kidney
loaded with cholesterol it's interesting
why is that because our bodies need
cholesterol for those organs right
caviar is very high in cholesterol cod
liver oil egg yolks that's where I get
my cholesterol butter cold water fish
lard so these are all foods that a lot
of people ate back in the early 20s and
30s but of course in the 40s and then
the 50s and 60s people just kind of got
them out of their diet but the truth is
that cholesterol deficiencies create
more problems than high cholesterol
thanks for watching I just want to take
a moment to thank you for your amazing
amazing successes that you guys are
writing about and I would love to have a
complete success story from you with a
before picture and an after picture as
well if you have that and I put a link
down below so you can fill it out if you
don't have a weight loss before and
after just put an image of yourself and
your success I would love to read it
and I would love to share it with others
because it does give them hope that they
could be helped too
thank you so much